you gotta give him different something
that they all worried about their
numbers where were you at their numbers
was in West Palm North America it was
crazy for a minute with riffraff
remember riffraff oh he's alive
Jodi high-roller yeah dude damn he's a
fan well there's nobody like him he's
that neon sasquatch you know dude
literally hanging out with him is like
hanging out with like a piece of science
or something like something that fell
off the periodic table and just landed
in a humane it really it doesn't feel
like you're hanging out with Spencer's
embody duty first of all he rolls up I'm
knocking on the door he rolls up on a
four-wheeler
right and he's like get on that bike in
here and I got on like a pedal bike on
the back I got a medal it was like
Titanic hell yeah oh yeah I didn't post
any picking up post pictures you can't
where you try to post him in they don't
post oh he's like a vampire yeah it's
crazy man he's next level I did a
podcast episode with him though oh so
you're gonna wait til that drops yeah do
I feel like you guys were separated at
Birth yes there's similarities there's
some Larry's a little bit in the way
though Milo's no you look exactly the
same right but he looks like he was
colored with a neon marker yeah it looks
like he got shot by like a silver bullet
like they tried to kill him when he was
young it looked like his mom [ __ ] a
Nerf ball we're leaving that in but I
didn't say laugh at that man he dude
he's the dude is hilarious man and I
love names - when dude he used to make
me laugh when he's trying to get big
steroids
he's off of it now oh he had a [ __ ]
uh he had like a handful of [ __ ] stem
cells he was just eating them like this
when I was over there
just [ __ ] cranberry stem cells baby
the tangerine Tiger Tail D'Antoni bro
with that million-dollar mullet son you
and him
if you and him create a podcast it would
be the best thing in the world oh dude
like he should replace me for sure no
man if you die yeah okay I mean you're
gonna die yes maybe especially now the
Jody high rollers well torn [ __ ] I'm
here at [ __ ] Brody low roller brah you
look like [ __ ] Brody Jenner just
[ __ ] came in nine thousand and a
Lance Armstrong bike off fro Andre
Agassi brother the [ __ ] wars I have
ever seen it looks like it's about love
love dude nobody's scored in this mother
you should be wearing a hat with you're
here you're here looks like a hate crime
to Africans in Chicago get beat up in
the back well I think we're all ready to
start good Jodi High Roller see so Mike
in music Judy just play he has all this
sweet love ballad that he's done
inspired cuz he got clown raise on that
show yeah MTV tattoo on his neck oh yeah
did he I don't remember that shut no I
loved it I forget arm school I think was
Charm School and no one took him serious
then he was super skinny like he's on
meth and then he got off the show and
then he's like the most successful one
Wow
yeah man it's a cool story I didn't know
that night but yes I love that show
don't even know that that's so funny I
don't even know that I just know man
he's the only white guy really wow what
a first of all brave guy okay super
brave also not that brave dude you go on
a school nine of the guys at school are
black how do you not win the contest
that's what I'm what a competition oh
well then there you go
that [ __ ] was great yeah that's it was
good because he got started on New York
New York right wasn't he a contestant on
there why is he really I thought so and
then you got put on that other show he
got booed off her she was crazy remember
she tried to repossess her mom's fake
tits member that late
we're always gonna crazy yes mom yeah we
looked like the female in gremlins 2
when she got all crazy but they lived a
mom the mom was like gremlins - mom oh
yeah remember there was a fire and they
both put on like the wrong wig and came
out real fast or something yeah one look
like David's
[Laughter]
[Music]